are they balloons caught in drafts or
alien crafts could it be the greatest
mystery in recent history who knows it's
time for
[Music]
holy hell it's like some kind of balloon
of palooza Extravaganza getting gate
Festival spectacular
[Laughter]
stupid
just stupid for three days in a row U.S
fighter jets shot down a trio that's
three Rob of unidentified objects over
Alaska Canada and Lake Huron Huron Huron
Iran who cares we haven't seen something
in public schools do what nothing well
anyway thank you we haven't seen
something get shot down this month since
Jimmy Fallon was single
oh Jimmy yeah nice one yeah nice one now
between the White House the Pentagon
NORAD who's a buddy of mine no one seems
to be able to say exactly what's going
on I guess none of that defense money
can comprehend balloon technology from
the 1700s
senior U.S officials said the ones over
Alaska and Canada are believed to be
balloons although Justin Trudeau claims
they only shot theirs because they
thought it was a trucker
[Laughter]
NORAD by Buddy says the one over Lake
was flying much lower than the others at
just 20 000 feet I hope it was E.T we
don't need any more sequels oh
kill it
and that one is interesting because
NORAD Chief General Glenn van hurk
wouldn't rule out anything including
extraterrestrials
and if they are aliens it raises the key
question which former New York luxury
hotels should we have
[Applause]
admitted they haven't been able to
definitively say what these most recent
objects are but added it's definitely
not aliens I know there have been
questions and and concerns about this
but there is no again no indication of
aliens or extraterrestrial activity with
these recent takedowns
it's amazing she even needed to look
down to read that
I say that as I do this
well maybe the big guy can shed some
light on all this what's going on here
Joe
yeah yeah yeah we're gonna take these
guys down and shoot him out of the sky
bang bang bang I got the balloon I got
these other three guys I know what
you're thinking it would you take six
shots or was it only five oh I gotta
tell you all the excitement I kind of
lost track myself you got to ask
yourself one question do you feel lucky
well do you punk
I'm kind of scared myself don't tell
anybody especially Kamala makes her
laugh
[Applause]
Michelle are we just now shooting
everything out of the sky to prove that
we aren't scared of uh because we blew
it the first time it feels like that it
really does it's like we let the wine
just skate across the country and then
we shot it down and then now we see the
next one it makes me wonder how many
there were prior to this because if this
if we just noticed the one in Montana
and people kind of looked up and went
hey look at that uh how many did we not
notice suddenly there's this cluster of
balloons and I think what scares the
bajevies yes the Beijing oh my God
what's the most is like what they can do
with this so they're kind of I feel like
they're kind of testing you know they're
seeing how what at what level do we get
noticed where do they shoot us down and
what can we put on or in this balloon to
do real real harm uh it's it scares me I
I and I'm losing faith Greg yeah it's
another institution the balloon industry
I no longer trust right as a child child
all I thought were wow I Love Balloons
and now I'm not so sure by faith in
balloons helium and otherwise has
essentially deflated
you hate balloons you must love watching
them getting blown to Pieces ah they
shot another one down you'd scream
I don't think about balloons very often
uh here either I don't know if I believe
this is happening all of a sudden yeah
like maybe like you said this has been
happening a lot and they're just now
talking about it like I don't believe
that there's no aliens just because they
tell me there's no aliens I don't
believe anything that they necessarily
say and I don't get why it's so crazy to
think that there could be aliens yeah or
that they're already here because I mean
like look around we're all in like
what's could be more insane than just
this well I mean like think about
viruses viruses are definitely an alien
species look at Jimmy I mean that's
tough love for Jimmy today wow Jimmy's
taking a lot of heat today yeah
yeah you deserve it I don't know you
know
um I believe and uh what are you done
sure
I said this today on the five and I'm
going to say it again these are we're
shooting down our own surveillance
balloons that we put up five years ago
it's very likely that's what we did
we're just shooting down our own crap
yeah right like shooting beer cans you
know we're finding we're finding money
in our jackets yeah you know what I mean
yes we go what is this spy balloon
um it's I almost want to believe it's
aliens but the reason being is it would
be explorative on their part to come
down here and check the place out if
it's another country it's really scary
just how much they're disrespecting
America by sending this stuff over here
in the fashion that they have you know
what I mean we used to have like real
respect on the world stage like speak
softly carry a big stick but now we have
Babel incoherently and carry a big
teleprompter and I don't think people
are scared but you think about the
weakness we're projecting like Biden
hasn't spoken yet okay we had never shot
anything down in 65 years of NORAD we've
now shot down four things in a week and
they can't send them out to the podium
because if somebody asks them about
aliens he's going to start talking about
Sigourney Weaver you know what I mean
she's hot she's great but it's a bad
look for us you know um you are
obviously a veteran in Hollywood use
your Hollywood imagination to create a
plot where I am the star let's be clear
that involves that explains this what's
going on we're in the first act right
now where I am the dedicated scientist
who knows something's going on and that
but we don't know what it is I love it
yes uh we're gonna go a different way
with your part okay so you know we're
gonna go for an actual star but but I
like where you're going uh but it was my
idea yeah you know that's funny that's
how it works
um I'm gonna get very rich on this idea
that is yours not new to Hollywood so
she know
the thing is I they are aliens and
here's how we know that they are aliens
because the bite Administration said
they were not aliens so I'm 100
convinced they're aliens but they're
kind of friendly they're like in a
balloon it's like kind of fun like yes
and they're gonna like be the next
aliens would come in a pinata or
something it's all going to be party
stuff and it's going to be great like we
I we thought that they were gonna we
thought aliens are gonna be like this at
like skinny with a big head and stuff
they're gonna be like guys in top hats
and Monicals like people balloonists
yeah balloonists and they're gonna and
and in that like look the cargo is like
maybe it's like some fruitcake that
they're it'll be nice it'll be nice yeah
why is everything so negative this is
gonna be this is good news the aliens
are coming to save us and there's a lot
for them to do yeah there is there is
and what are we doing we're shooting
them down shot them down you know that's
the other problem we gotta not do that
because we want we gotta you know see
them in their monocles marching up and
down the mall it'd be great and I always
go back to this you know we eat
earthlings right now right we eat cattle
that's an Earthling right we eat lamb
that's an Earthling I want I would like
to eat them uh because it would I would
just like to eat an alien just because
it's it's on my bucket list wow you know
what you have too much money
that is a rich guy thing to say yeah you
know what it is I'm tired of the steak
and the caviar Kobe beef so your second
assistant get me an alien right now
you know what they say it's the most
dangerous that's right that's right that
game yeah yeah me I think it's wild game
I got the most dangerous games yeah
playing off a Hollywood classic movies
starring who was in The Most Dangerous
Game Cornell Wilde wow I think so that
he was a strange dude Poor Man's Robert
Conrad this is I just love that we're
playing a game called Google it or
change the channel
oh you're a jerk hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else